what's going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are here to continue
Brooklyn 99. we're gonna watch episode 2
of season five The Big House part dose
you know what to Do's leaves is alike
that would be very much appreciated but
love it also subscribe click the
notification Bell get notified on our
next reaction from Brooklyn nine nine is
up here on the channel as always for
super sexy rejects the full anthraction
watching along is available that is our
patreon page but we cover a bunch of
stuff over there exclusively as well uh
many of those shows the reaction
highlights and watch alongs included
alrighty I am ready to do this thing
so I got assigned to this one rookie and
on his training day I made him smoke
angel dust at gunpoint more beard movie
Training Day yes great observation tank
it's because it's based on my life lunch
is over what's your Trace now Peralta I
haven't finished my lemon cookie give it
to me oh you want the cookie
[Music]
he's got a delivery coming in on
Wednesday night we'll see you Thursday
you're just gonna leave me in here in
solitary you spit in a guard's face
that's five days in the hole oh we don't
want anybody getting suspicious huh oh
what a jerk
time days is nothing I'm not afraid to
be alone with my thoughts my thoughts
are awesome Die Hard 6 on a cruise ship
pizza bagel restaurant my father never
loved me and I'm gonna die alone oh boy
that happened fast guard
s
maybe your dad can come visit you in
prison
Rosa in prison
yeah my name is Sheamus Murphy yeah I
know who you are every cop in the city
does that could give you the proof you
need to take down the cop that set him
up what whoa how would you do that I'll
do you a favor one day you do me a favor
think about it oh my but don't think too
hard
you only got three days
who is that guy he just signed the book
that he wrote
to my Biggest Fan Amy Solitaire it was
nothing I held it together maybe
you're lucky
real good girl
how's the movie
yep we busted Romero's delivery look at
this
nothing but toothbrushes shampoo and
soap you ever heard of blizz yeah drug
right and thanks to your pal Romero is
taking over the prison find the stash or
I'll tell everybody you're a snitch whoa
dude will probably be a lot of paperwork
for you oh it's not it's just one form
and it's already filled out we just have
to staple a picture of your corpse to it
prison is great
that sucks sorry three days to decide
there
Murphy didn't ask me to do anything
illegal he just wants me to owe him a
favor but we've been watching Hawkins
for a month and we have nothing to
connect her to the robberies maybe we
should pursue other routes some of us
are already pursuing other routes Amy
this is Charles Boyle and you're oh
detective Peralta a God In Shadows this
podcast is brought to you by Fun frames
make your spectacles a spectacle and how
is your podcast and stamps.com people
see he was framed I build an audience I
get a celebrity listener it's Deborah
Messing she tweets a link now Sean Hayes
is involved
[Laughter]
he says that Hawkins is moving the
diamonds in three days that's a new lead
let's work it instead of putting your
career in Jefferson we're all excited
about the same thing
head in the game I'm clearly going to be
here for a while I want to live my best
prison life and that means doing more
for the gang you're great at what you do
you don't need me you're going to make
me think you're a snitch and you know
what I do to snitches give them a public
dressing down
specific policy love the attitude love
you love all of this okay see you in the
mess hall Romero by Romero I need your
help that's what friends are for well
friends might be a bit of a stretch I
mean you're a cannibal that ate six
people nine and a half
a I keep pestering ramire to tell me
where the drugs are here what's option b
i back off Romero never find out where
the drugs are the warden tells everyone
I'm a snitch and then Romero castrates
me and kicks me to death I just do what
I do best Forge a new identity and then
take a job as a camp counselor
I need to do what I do best be a cop
figure out where the drugs are on my own
and you tell the ward and the Warren
will bust Romero and Romero will think
I'm a snitch because he never told me
where they are I'm really gonna have to
thread the needle oh I got really good
at threading needles but we're friends
friends
[Laughter]
Hawkins has two different phones her
normal cell and then this one that only
has one app on home screen Snapchat
Snapchat messages disappear nobody asks
Hitchcock why he knows that could we put
a mirroring app on our phone so we can
watch everything she does you have to
physically have her phone to install it
oh Jesus dude
we get her to visit prison they make you
leave your phone in your car I want to
record Jake for the podcast but they
said I couldn't I had to have carry on
as a guest I gave up my Saturday for
that you said I did great I'm the host I
have to say that oh Terry we're great
how do I stop myself from smashing
through the glass and squeezing the life
out of her with my bare hands you're
probably just as fun as actually doing
it right no I'm with Diaz imagination is
never the solution we just need three
minutes oh okay I can gravel for three
minutes but one second more yes we know
you burst through the glass and squeeze
the life out of it with your bare hands
well I think we have a plan
she's really gonna come I gotta tell you
cop work is a lot like Hannibal work
they're watching
The Following
they're waiting for soccer practice to
end oh dude
mayor just went into the showers for the
second time today what's he doing in
there
it must be where stash is the Bliss
unless he's just having sex nobody's a
huge homophobe it's where he sashes the
place oh homophobes are secretly gay you
know what it doesn't matter
shots fired
we'll get the phone Captain Holmes can
you distract a lot of attendance I'm not
Captain Holt I'm Joe Wozniak here to see
my girl in prison to help me pass as
straight oh
little Rosa Diaz so I hear you want me
to put in a good word for you with the
warden yes please I love this this is so
much fun for me just trying to work up
the nerve to see her see who my female
wife Crystal
[Laughter]
's named Jamie Lynn tonight when I was
philandering Crystal caught me kissing
Jamie Lynn's
heavy breasts
that's the signal go
Wowie
good more with sugar on top more
caramel drizzle 35 seconds on the
download it just seems like you want to
be with Jamie I mean you keep talking
about a thigh gap that's my favorite
part of a woman there's nothing more
intoxicating than the clear absence of a
penis
I'm off oh my God plow my mistress more
time's up
yes oh my God that's awesome oh [__]
whoa oh yes hello
you don't even beg well have fun rotting
in prison
okay thanks for coming in that's a nice
bit yeah that's clever have me for a
second
I found something what is this melon
baller wait a minute Romero doesn't
stash the drugs in here he comes in here
to make the blizzballs he smuggles the
blizz into the prison in the soap dish
no in the soap it's in the soap oh yeah
hey you don't think you can get high
from rubbing drugs unlike your eyes and
armpits and up under your B parts can
you you definitely can here it comes
are you listening huh are you Mr Warden
I think we should be able to decorate
our own cells don't you I mean shoes
around wallpaper laminated
why am I here Liz yes Romero smuggling
the place into the prison as far as the
soap interesting and that's good work I
know I am the smartest man of egg time
egg time egg time egg time that was it a
butler supplement
don't get stabbed she unlocked the phone
she's in the app and she's typing bus
station Linden New Jersey pick up five
team we have one hour you're on a crazy
amount of blizz but your brain still
works the warden was yelling at me are
you on Blues because you just told us
okay Jake don't freak out just stay calm
yep I am nips deep and Bliss
yeah what kind of cop does that much
meth not meth Bliss yeah that's meth we
just call it blizz because Smith has a
bit of an image problem oh oh my God I
guess I'm addicted to meth no I have not
I just love it and I'm consumed with the
thought of doing it again
[Laughter]
smart congratulations
you're one of only two people who know
ah oh jeez I've got eyes on Locker 805.
I'm with the inside of both exits copy
that it's almost five where's Boyd
Shalom Amy
Charles all done we don't need disguises
anyone can be here typical I see
movement at the locker
get down
touch the back
oh boy knights Bishop to Queen five bye
now
she set us up
what do you want Peralta stop everything
Romero told me that the blizz is in the
soap if you take away his Supply he'll
know I'm the snitch and kill me I
already made the report to my bosses and
they were very pleased Glenn couldn't
stop smiling Glenn you don't know what a
big deal that is
[Laughter]
way more than 200 pounds which means
they're finishing pigs and why would a
farmer force feed a finishing Pig
because he was feeding them something
other
for the reacher show
yep perfect timing
I told you what I do the stitches oh
dear Romero Caleb what are you doing
it's okay Jake I got this Paratha is my
best friend if you want to kill him
you're gonna have to kill me
your next Paratha you better sleep with
one eye open
sure I need I need sure you were right
Pig's stomachs were full of Diamonds oh
found the diamonds and Langdon confessed
it's over Hawkins Pawn to King Square
Five King's night to the third Square on
the beach
don't have seven yes Checkmate chest
mate your squad busted Melanie Hawk just
one time you're getting out can I do one
thing first I wanted to say goodbye I
can't believe you saved my life and I
regret it so much Caleb you're ruining
put it there pal
oh
my God the warm 99 welcome to Jake broth
and Rosa Diaz I never saw Rose in prison
once nope can I buy a free man a drink
I'd rather have a drink of that mouth oh
I'm sorry
hello I'm also back here is it so I
already spent some time in solitary he
said pretty dope right
so Robbie and I didn't see you at the
presentation of Simba oh Mufasa did I
miss it that's simply oh
I handled it well leave your obscure
knowledge of pig beating chart saved us
how'd you even think of that frankly I'm
embarrassed it took so long I should
have realized the second I saw those
Hogs hello so Captain Holt did my
information prove useful were the
diamonds in the pigs yes you were right
oh [__] and don't even think about
screwing me
nothing we're doing toast the 99th
Precinct is officially all back together
nine nine
[Applause]
oh that's dark
dark it was dark that was great great
I'm gonna miss Lou Diamond Phillips yeah
man I thought they did a much better job
with that than they did when Jake had to
go in the witness protection program and
also including when they had to um
no wait yeah yeah they went on Windows
production program in Florida Jake was
undercover and then there was one where
he was Witness Protection Program with
Holt yeah I thought they did a better
job here because you can still actually
feel the time because you know they only
do it in two episodes but you could
actually really feel it feels like
they've been there a long time yeah yeah
and you and you could feel the uh
compounding stakes and weight of the
entire situation at hand uh which I
thought was really excellent because it
it was suspenseful and even though the
second it was like okay yeah he's gonna
get out this episode because there's no
way he can just survive this but in
spite of that it was still really fun
and exciting and you know I thought it
was cool that he didn't uh remain snitch
and how he copped his way out of there
yeah but yeah they have a they have a
real cop show intensity about it this
time surviving prison Holt having to get
in bed with the mafia oh man that's
great that's great stuff I thought they
did an excellent job here it was really
fun and exciting and
I feel like that's such a common Trope
though of like give it into the animals
uh of like hiding stuff in animals
that's right man literally we haven't
finished Richard yet so but that was
been one of my theories for a reason
that the criminals are hiding it in the
animals so uh and so I'm like I feel
like maybe they could have gone in there
a little on their own
yeah like do you need even the the the
the help of the mob to realize such a
such a circumstance I don't know but the
sacrifice that he made it he was so
desperate to save and win after being
provoked by
um what's the villain's name
I keep trying to cover it
um that Melanie something yeah I could
see why Holt will probably hey you can
fathom a couple reasons why Holt would
go down that rabbit hole but more
importantly this was also a hysterical
episode yeah yeah yeah there was some
really funny reoccurring bits I love the
thing about Terry suck it at the podcast
um yeah Hitchcock having all the weird
Snapchat and mirroring apps knowledge
yeah the the bits about
um like with the Blitz and or blizz and
the way the way they did like actual
visual gags like they zooming on his
eyes to make you think it's on he's
talking from his head yeah oh and he
just said it out loud I thought it was
really funny or uh they had us go they
had me going at least uh with Rosa uh
breaking down the glass yeah I thought
that was real at first I thought it was
real too and uh but and and the way they
set that joke up about imagination and
not completely giving away I thought was
really well done and you see that she's
actually satisfied with the Imagine
imaginative thought there I thought it
was a really funny episode and I think
the art that they did here uh is leading
from last season the way last season
ended to where we had with these two
episodes you could have had genuine
Stakes
um I I thought it was really exciting
and really funny it was a really funny
really funny Arc and I like how it's not
just ending and we're going back to
normal that we have a cliffhanger that
we're gonna see carry on and it just has
to carry on this uh ripple effect from
the decision that Holt ultimately made
the last person you'd expect to make a
decision yeah the handoff of that for
maybe two hold yeah and you know
probably did it too that guy being
desperate and gotta saved gotta save
Jake and Rosa but also doesn't want
Amy's career to be on the line that's
good that was that was really awesome
yeah man agree it's like I could have I
could have easily watched this for three
episodes or or whatever but uh but yeah
like I feel like when they do something
out of the precinct out of the ordinary
like this I guess two is kind of their
sweet spot and yeah I agree I thought
they they rounded this one out more and
you know they leave you wanting but not
in a bad way I'm just like yeah this is
so fun to see Lou Diamond Phillips and
his crew Tim Meadows Caleb the cannibal
uh is another like great character who I
hope at some point could maybe make a a
reappearance just you know because he's
just so funny at being this weird
unassuming guy
um but yeah no absolutely and Toby Haas
as the warden like just a lot of like
great
it sort of hit me during this one like
oh this Arc has been like star-studded
it's like a lot of get I feel like you
usually get like a guest or two at a
time whereas this one has like three
plus you know other character actors and
stuff like that three four and yeah it's
just like the the the pace and the
tension like I never you know kind of
left the immediacy of the moment even
when we were cutting back to the
precinct and stuff like that and uh and
the whole like chess game back and forth
It's like you can you can kind of tell
like okay them getting the drop on her
with the phone is probably not gonna
work out
um and then I like that you know at at
first when the episode was wrapping up I
was like oh oh we're I guess we got her
okay and then you know having that
Revelation that Holt did take this you
know this deal uh from this you know
mobster guy kind of helps to justify
that you know it's it's a desperate
measure but it uh yeah it freaking gets
the job done uh so yeah I thought this
was nicely pitched and oriented and I
love seeing Jake in these situations
where he is completely sort of out of
his element uh and forced to navigate
places like prison or the mob or you
know elements where he doesn't want to
fully go against you know obviously what
he knows is right or wrong as a cop
um and just yeah I don't know watching
him have to blend in and all that stuff
is so fun so yeah uh that was awesome
that was awesome and uh also uh Andy
Samberg was amazing too I loved his like
the constant uh at on the edge of a seat
he was the entire time the paranoia he
was feeling and and how much that just
kept escalating and him just trying to
like keep it together but
also just maintaining the humor like he
hit the right pitch to to keep it like
believable for the Jake Peralta
character but also really funny I
thought he I thought he was really this
to me showcased some of his best work oh
sure he's two episodes here I thought
were uh it was awesome uh here he's not
even like relying on the usual people
he's bouncing off of oh yeah he's not
with any of them he's got to be the
center in a lot of ways of those moments
yeah
um because you know it's about not not
to discret or downplay but yeah it's
usually like you're the comfortable the
people you're most comfortable with the
cast the series regulars and here he's
just with a whole bunch of new
characters yeah yeah I really he really
LED it like like he was he saw a lead
for these two episodes looks good with a
beard too I know I missed it looked
weird when it didn't have any more
um would have liked to have seen a
little bit more of rose's prison
experience but I guess it doesn't really
pertain to the plot so that's fine yeah
what are you gonna do all right guys
well uh thank you so much for being here
uh be sure to leave a like follow us on
patreon and we'll so you guys soon